los manifestantes en mianmar no muestran
signos de rendición y han vuelto a salir
a las calles el jueves por la mañana
incluso ante el aumento de la represión
por parte de la junta militar la noche
anterior las fuerzas de seguridad
dispararon balas de goma sobre los
manifestantes en la ciudad de mandalay
los trabajadores del ferrocarril pararon
trenes como parte del movimiento de
desobediencia civil y cientos de miles
de manifestantes a lo largo del país
tomaron las calles en medio de las
huelgas en curso las grandes protestas
de hoy muestran que queremos que la
comunidad internacional sepa que no nos
vamos a rendir
les estamos instando a actuar
las protestas también se están llevando
a cabo en la red
el grupo hackers de mianmar atacó varias
páginas web gubernamentales al tiempo
que los militares siguen con el corte de
internet en la capital hubo plegarias
por la recuperación de mí a tuit uequín
y una joven de 20 años herida de bala en
la cabeza en una manifestación el 9 de
febrero los médicos no esperan que
sobreviva la onu está presionando para
imponer sanciones económicas y decretar
un embargo de armas ante el temor de que
la violencia se recrudezca con esta web
el pueblo de mianmar es consciente de lo
que es capaz del ejército y estos
generales porque ya lo he visto
por eso la presencia del ejército de
tropas expone nervio mentón
eeuu ha instado al ejército birmano a
poner en libertad a todos los civiles y
líderes políticos detenidos de manera
injusta aún san suu kyi la líder electa
democráticamente fue arrestada al inicio
del golpe y se espera que comparezca
ante la justicia el primero